Okay, let's turn to Stratton's fifth technique,
which he refers to as binning or spatial data structures.
So say you've got an algorithm where certain input elements
will contribute to certain output elements.
In technique 2, we talked about transforming this from a scatter operation,
where you assign threads to the input elements to perform the computation,
and then they figure out where to write,
to a gather operation, where you assign threads the output elements,
and they figure out where to go read from.
Now sometimes it can be hard to orchestrate this gather operation, right?
It can be hard to figure out which inputs matter for a given output.
One thing you can always do is you could have every thread
assigned to an output element, check every possible input element
to see if this input element will contribute to this output element.
But obviously, that's going to be ruinously expensive if you take it too far.
So what we want to do is optimize away most of the redundant work
that you would be doing if all of these threads were checking all of these inputs
to see if they contribute.
And we're going to call this binning.
So binning is when you build a data structure
that maps output locations to the relevant input data.
And a point that I want to make is that this will work best
when you're mapping output locations to a relatively small subset of the input data.
Stratton and company called a creation of this data structure binning,
because it often reflects a sorting of the input in to bins
that contain often a region of space,
representing a region of space containing those input elements that are relevant.
So let's look at an example.